Vous connaissez Jean-Claude Dusse ?
C’est un personnage CULTE
de la série de films Les Bronzés.
Célibataire,
il passe ses vacances dans des clubs
PLUS pour faire des rencontres
que pour se reposer.
Seulement,
il est TRÈS maladroit.
Il dit souvent :
« Je vais conclure. »
— mais il ne conclut jamais.
Vous savez pourquoi ?
Parce qu’il n’a PAS COMPRIS
que la conclusion,
ça se passe
APRÈS
la séduction.
Qu’est-ce que ça veut dire,
« conclure » ?
Le verbe « conclure »
vient du verbe latin
CONCLUDERE
qui signifie « fermer ».
Conclure,
ça veut donc dire
METTRE FIN
à un processus.
Dans un processus de séduction,
ça veut dire obtenir
ce qu’on attend
de l’autre personne.
Le problème de Jean-Claude Dusse,
vous l’avez compris,
c’est qu’il veut conclure
AVANT MÊME
d’avoir séduit.
Or,
ce qu’il doit réussir à faire,
c’est SÉDUIRE
— et alors conclure sera facile,
ça se fera tout seul.
C’est la MÊME CHOSE
en dissertation :
ne faites pas la même erreur
que Jean-Claude Dusse ;
n’essayez pas DE SÉDUIRE,
lorsque l’enjeu est
de CONCLURE !
À quoi sert
une conclusion de dissertation ?
simplement À RAPPELER
les RÉSULTATS
de la réflexion
— pas à SÉDUIRE.
La séduction du correcteur,
ça se joue
dans L’INTRODUCTION,
et dans une moindre mesure
dans le développement de votre dissertation.
Et pour séduire le correcteur,
vous avez surtout besoin d’UNE CHOSE :
une méthodologie EFFICACE.
Vous en voulez une ?
Inscrivez-vous
à mon cours GRATUIT
de méthodologie de la dissertation
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
soit en utilisant celui
qui est dans la description de cette vidéo.
C’est un cours par e-mail,
donc vous pouvez d’abord regarder cette
vidéo,
et puis vous lirez mon cours après,
ou bien dans quelques jours.
J’en reviens à la conclusion
de la dissertation.
Comme je vous l’ai dit,
l’enjeu n’est PAS
de séduire le correcteur
— et donc il y a d’abord
des choses que vous devez ÉVITER
de faire.
Je vais d’abord vous parler de ça
dans cette vidéo :
je vais vous donner
ma NOT-TO-DO LIST
de la conclusion.
Je vous révèlerai ensuite
mes deux FORMULES
pour rédiger
une BONNE
conclusion de dissertation :
ma formule IDÉALE,
lorsque vous avez au moins
cinq dix minutes
pour écrire la conclusion ;
puis ma formule EXPRESS,
grâce à laquelle vous pourrez
rédiger une conclusion
dans l’urgence,
en une deux minutes maximum.
Regardez attentivement cette vidéo jusqu’au
bout
et vous économiserez du temps
ET DU STRESS
DÈS
votre prochaine épreuve de dissertation.
Pour rédiger FACILEMENT
la conclusion d’une dissertation,
il y a deux choses
que vous ne devez PAS faire.
La première,
c’est L’OUVERTURE.
Qu’est-ce que l’ouverture ?
Vous le savez probablement :
ce sont la,
ou les toutes dernières phrases
de la conclusion d’une dissertation.
Elles sont censées
ÉLARGIR le propos,
OUVRIR de nouvelles perspectives
— et les partisans de l’ouverture
n’en disent jamais plus.
Cette définition suffit pour comprendre
le problème de l’ouverture.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ?
Eh bien,
on nage dans le vague !
« ÉLARGIR le propos »,
« OUVRIR de nouvelles perspectives » :
qu’est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Qu’est-ce qu’il faut faire
PRÉCISÉMENT ?
Voici donc la première raison pour laquelle
vous n’avez PAS intérêt
à rédiger une ouverture :
il n’existe pas de consigne
PRÉCISE.
Il y a QUATRE autres raisons
pour lesquelles
il vaut mieux éviter de faire une ouverture
:
vous risquez de souligner une idée
qui aurait mérité de figurer dans le développement
(et du coup,
vous mettez en évidence
une faille dans votre argumentation…) ;
vous risquez d’évoquer
une idée banale
ou maladroite ;
puisqu’il faut aller
ENCORE PLUS LOIN
dans la réflexion,
faire une ouverture
demande une maîtrise de la discipline
et une maturité intellectuelle
propres à un prof,
pas à un élève ;
enfin,
comme vous êtes à la toute fin de l’épreuve
de dissertation,
vous manquez probablement de temps.
En fait,
s’embêter à faire une ouverture,
ce n’est PAS DU TOUT rentable
— c’est un DÉTAIL
dont vous vous préoccuperez
au détriment
de L’ESSENTIEL.
Gardez plutôt les quelques minutes
que vous y consacreriez
pour vous relire avec plus de soin.
Vous trouverez probablement des fautes d’orthographe
qui feraient mauvaise impression sur le correcteur.
Pour vous convaincre,
je vais vous montrer un exemple
tiré d’un site QUI CONSEILLE,
lui,
de faire une ouverture
à la fin de la conclusion.
Regardez :
Lisons l’ouverture
pour BIEN nous rendre compte du problème
:
« Ainsi,
il est possible de s’interroger
sur la responsabilité des terroristes
quant à leurs actes.
Les frères Tsarnaev sont considérés
comme étant responsables des attentats
qu’ils ont commis le 15 avril 2013
lors du Marathon de Boston.
Toutefois,
on peut se demander s’ils étaient libres
et conscients de leurs actions
ou non.
»
Est-ce que vous pensez
que c’est une BONNE idée
de terminer une dissertation de philosophie
sur la liberté
en invitant à réfléchir
à la responsabilité des TERRORISTES ?
Je ne critique pas
la pertinence de l’idée qui est exprimée,
mais LE CHOIX
de cette idée.
Le terrorisme est un sujet complexe et sensible
qui divise la société ;
en parler en ouverture,
c’est prendre le risque de dire une bêtise
et de heurter la sensibilité du correcteur.
En l’occurrence,
on pouvait trouver des idées moins risquées
à la place,
mais le plus simple est
DE NE PAS
faire d’ouverture !
Voilà,
j’espère que l’exemple
vous a convaincu.
SECONDE chose
à NE PAS faire
dans une conclusion de dissertation :
mobiliser une connaissance.
Je vous l’ai déjà dit dans mon accroche
:
la conclusion sert à METTRE FIN
au processus de séduction,
et non pas à séduire.
J’ai lu tellement de copies
qui se terminent par un vers de poésie,
par une citation,
ou par une référence originale !
Les élèves qui font ça croient
qu’ils vont impressionner le correcteur
à la TOUTE FIN de la dissertation,
mais généralement
l’introduction
et le développement
ont déjà DÉÇU
le correcteur.
En fait,
c’est LA MÊME CHOSE
que dans les interactions sociales :
ce n’est pas UNE PHRASE,
une PUNCHLINE,
que vous lancez à la fin de l’interaction
qui va vous sauver,
et persuader l’autre personne
de vous accorder
ce que vous attendez d’elle.
Non,
c’est surtout ce que vous faites
et ce que vous dites
AU DÉBUT,
et puis tout au long
de l’interaction.
Ne tombez donc pas dans le fantasme,
et ne vous prenez pas la tête
à essayer d’impressionner le correcteur
À LA TOUTE FIN
de la dissertation.
Souvenez-vous donc :
PAS d’ouverture,
ni de connaissance,
dans une conclusion de dissertation.
Voilà,
je vous ai expliqué
ce qu’il ne faut PAS faire.
Maintenant,
je vais vous dire
ce qu’il FAUT
faire.
Je vais d’abord vous dire
ce que vous devez faire
dans des circonstances NORMALES
de rédaction
— c’est-à-dire si vous avez LE TEMPS
d’écrire une bonne conclusion.
C’est,
d’après moi,
la formule IDÉALE
pour une conclusion de dissertation.
Sur quelle idée repose ma formule ?
L’idée,
c’est que pour rappeler les résultats
de votre réflexion,
vous devez RÉSUMER
votre cheminement intellectuel.
C’est un peu
comme lorsque vous donnez les directions
à une personne
qui vous demande le chemin
dans la rue :
« vous allez à droite,
puis tout droit,
et quand vous apercevrez telle chose,
tel immeuble
ou tel magasin,
là vous tournerez à gauche,
etc.
»
Eh bien,
vous devez faire LA MÊME CHOSE
dans la conclusion d’une dissertation
— mais dans le monde des idées.
Maintenant que vous avez compris
LE PRINCIPE
de ma formule,
je vous dévoile
LA FORMULE
elle-même.
C’est très simple :
vous commencez par rappeler
le point de départ de votre réflexion ;
et ensuite vous allez faire
LA MÊME CHOSE
pour chaque grande partie :
vous rappelez l’idée générale de la partie
en une phrase ;
PUIS
vous synthétisez les arguments
de cette même partie
en une phrase.
Par exemple,
si vous avez rédigé une dissertation
en trois grandes parties
de trois paragraphes
— c’est-à-dire trois grandes parties
de trois arguments chacune —
eh bien si vous avez rédigé
une telle dissertation,
ALORS votre conclusion
aura la structure suivante :
rappel du point de départ de la réflexion
;
rappel de l’idée du grand un ;
synthèse des arguments du grand un ;
rappel de l’idée du grand deux ;
synthèse des arguments du grand deux ;
rappel de l’idée du grand trois ;
synthèse des arguments du grand trois.
Si vous avez bien compté,
ça fait SEPT PHRASES
au total :
une phrase
pour le point de départ de votre réflexion,
puis deux phrases par grande partie
(une phrase pour rappeler l’idée de la
grande partie,
et une pour synthétiser les arguments).
De manière générale,
si votre dissertation comporte N GRANDES PARTIES,
vous devrez écrire 2N + 1 PHRASES
en conclusion.
Je vous rappelle :
une phrase
pour le point de départ de votre réflexion,
puis deux phrases
par grande partie
(une phrase pour rappeler l’idée de la
grande partie,
et une pour synthétiser les arguments).
Je vous montre un exemple.
Voici la conclusion de ma dissertation sur
le sujet
« Philosopher,
est-ce apprendre à mourir ? ».
Le point de départ de ma réflexion
est surligné en jaune.
Les rappels des idées des grandes parties
sont en rouge
— enfin un genre de rouge.
Et les synthèses des arguments
sont surlignées en bleu clair.
Si vous voulez voir plus d’exemples,
lisez mon article
sur la conclusion de la dissertation
— j’ai mis le lien
dans la description de cette vidéo.
Voilà,
vous connaissez maintenant
ma formule IDÉALE
pour rédiger la conclusion d’une dissertation.
Avec cette formule,
vous écrirez FACILEMENT,
presque AUTOMATIQUEMENT,
des conclusions EFFICACES
et CONSISTANTES.
Mais COMMENT FAIRE
si vous n’avez PAS
le temps ?
Assez souvent,
vous n’avez PAS
le temps
de rédiger
la conclusion de votre dissertation.
Vous avez mal géré votre temps,
et vous vous rendez compte
qu’il ne vous reste
que quelques minutes
pour rédiger la conclusion.
Bon,
la PREMIÈRE CHOSE
que vous devez savoir,
c’est :
ce n’est PAS GRAVE.
Vous n’allez pas RATER
votre dissertation
parce que vous écrivez la conclusion
à l’arrache.
Donc reprenez-vous,
l’angoisse est inutile.
Oui,
vous êtes dans une situation d’urgence,
mais qu’est-ce que je vous ai dit
au début de cette vidéo :
ON S’EN FOUT
de la conclusion !
Vous le savez bien :
ce n’est pas GRÂCE
à la conclusion
que vous allez réussir
la dissertation !
Bon,
maintenant que vous avez compris ça,
quel est l’objectif à atteindre
si vous n’avez
QUE QUELQUES MINUTES
pour rédiger votre conclusion ?
L’objectif,
c’est de réussir à écrire quelques lignes
qui rappellent les résultats de la réflexion
LE PLUS RAPIDEMENT POSSIBLE.
Vous devez donner l’IMPRESSION
au correcteur
qu’il y a bien une conclusion
qui « fait le job ».
Étant donné
que vous devez être très rapide,
vous ne devez pas avoir à réfléchir,
vous ne devez pas chercher vos mots.
La solution,
c’est donc…
le COPIER-COLLER !
Voici donc ma formule EXPRESS
pour rédiger
la conclusion d’une dissertation :
vous recopiez la première phrase
du paragraphe de problématisation
de votre introduction,
c’est-à-dire la phrase qui présente
le point de départ de votre réflexion ;
et ensuite,
vous recopiez grosso modo
votre annonce de plan,
en consacrant une phrase
à chaque grande partie
— c’est-à-dire que si vous avez annoncé
votre plan
en une seule longue phrase,
eh bien vous mettez des points
à la place des virgules.
Avec cette formule EXPRESS,
la conclusion d’une dissertation en trois
parties
fera quatre phrases
(une phrase pour le point de départ de la
réflexion,
et une pour l’idée
de chaque grande partie).
Et de manière générale,
si une dissertation comporte N PARTIES,
eh bien une conclusion EXPRESS
fera N+1 PHRASES
(encore une fois :
une phrase pour le point de départ de la
réflexion,
et une pour l’idée de chaque grande partie).
Voici par exemple
ce que ça donnerait
pour ma dissertation sur le sujet
« Philosopher,
est-ce apprendre à mourir ? » :
La phrase qui présente le point de départ
de la réflexion
est surlignée en jaune ;
puis les idées des trois grandes parties
sont surlignées
chacune d’une couleur différente.
Si vous voulez voir plus d’exemples,
lisez mon article sur la conclusion de la
dissertation
— j’ai mis le lien
dans la description de la vidéo.
Voilà,
vous connaissez maintenant
ma formule EXPRESS
pour rédiger la conclusion d’une dissertation.
Avec cette formule,
vous pouvez écrire la conclusion
EN MOINS D’UNE MINUTE.
PLUS vous avez de temps,
plus vous avez intérêt à REFORMULER
le point de départ de votre réflexion
et votre annonce de plan.
En revanche,
si vous devez rendre votre copie
le plus vite possible,
alors ne réfléchissez pas :
COPIEZ-COLLEZ.
Si le correcteur s’en rend compte
— ce qui est possible —
eh bien s’il s’en rend compte,
il ne vous en tiendra pas rigueur.
Et puis de toute manière,
vous l’aurez déjà séduit
avec votre introduction !
Je vous l’ai déjà dit :
pour SÉDUIRE
le correcteur,
vous avez besoin
d’une BONNE MÉTHODO.
Je vous invite donc
à vous inscrire pour recevoir
mon cours GRATUIT
de méthodologie de la dissertation
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
soit en utilisant celui
qui est dans la description de cette vidéo.
Si vous avez des questions
sur la conclusion de la dissertation,
n’hésitez pas à me les poser dans les
commentaires,
et je vous répondrai avec plaisir.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Rappelez-vous
que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête
— et là VRAIMENT PAS —
vous n’avez VRAIMENT PAS besoin
de vous prendre la tête
pour réussir
la conclusion de la dissertation.